يتدحرج الوضع المستعر على الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه لاوكرانيا بشكل لافت نحو تصعيد
اكبر في ظل تصريحات روسيه اوكرانيه
متلاحقه بدورها وزير الدفاع الروسي تحدث
عن القوه الاوكرانيه
منذ الرابع من الشهر الجاري في محاور
جنوبولوجيا واشار الى خطه اوكرانيه لضرب
شبه جزيره القرم بصواريخ غربيه
ووفقا لمعلوماتنا فان القياده الاوكرانيه
تخطط لضرب الاراضي الروسيه بما فيها شبه
جزيره القرن بصواريخ هاي مارس وستور شادو
استخدام هذه الصواريخ خارجه منطقه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه يعني المشاركه الكامله
للولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في الصراع
تصنف منظومه هاي مارس الامريكيه على انها
وحده سلاح متنقله يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ عده
في وقت متزامن وتحمل الصواريخ هايمارس على
راجمه تحمل كل واحده منها سته صواريخ
دقيقه التوجيه بمدى يبلغ نحو 70 كيلومترا
اما صواريخ ظل العاصفه ستارتشادو
البريطانيه فيبلغ مداها اكثر من 155 ميلا
اي ثلاثه اضعاف مدى الصواريخ التي
استخدمتها اوكرانيا حتى الان وعلى خط
تزويد كييف بالاسلحه اكد الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون ان نظام الدفاع الجوي
متوسطه المدى الفرنسيه الايطالي سامبتي
جرى توريده الى اوكرانيا ويستخدم الصاروخ
استر 30 للدفاع الجوي البالستي ويتمتع
بمدن يتراوح بين ثلاثه ومئه وعشرين
كيلومترا تتغير معطيات الحرب ويتغير بنك
الاهداف مع تزود كياف باسلحه جديده ففيما
الماضي استهدف صاروخ شادو مقرا عسكريا
روسيا في ميناء مدينه برديانسك على بعد 70
ميلا تقريبا من مواقع الخطوط الاماميه
الاوكرانيه وتواجه احدى عشره منطقه داخل
مقاطعه الروسيه الحدوديه ضربات بشكل مستمر
وتشهد هذه المناطق توغلات اوكرانيه متكرره
وفق موسكو كما تبقى روستوف الحدوديه
جنوبيه روسيا ايضا مسرحا لهجمات صاروخيه
او بطائره مسيره مع تصدي دفاعات الجويه
لها وعلى الحدود وضعت سلطات مقاطعه كورس
كالروسيه كل سيناريوهات لاجلاء سكان القرى
والبلدات الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا بسبب
مواصفاتها بالمخاطر المحتمله لمجموعات
تخريب اوكرانيه مدير جهاز الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه قال ان الجيش الروسي يصد
هجوما مضادا لتجمع قوه النيتو وليس هجوما
اوكرانيا بينما قال الامين العام للنيتو
ان الحلف ليس طرفا في الصراع في اوكرانيا
ارد الروسي لا يتاخر بدوره فوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت قبل ايام تدمير راجمه
تايمرز امريكيه بصاروخ موجه براجمه
الصواريخ الروسيه تورنادو اس وهي قادره
على ضرب العدو بدقه على مسافات تصل الى
120 كم